James is with us in Youngstown Ohio
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show James oh
yeah better than I deserve what's up to
me $12,500 when he died but he did not
leave it to my mom that my sister and
any of his trip and I'm saying what I
should do a thing I got my baby stuck -
why did he leave you the money and no
one else he wasn't talking to them when
he set this up to my parents for my
sister mm-hmm was he when he died yes
ne-never transcript mm-hmm okay well
it's not a lot of money it's not a
million two hundred and fifty it's
twelve now it's 12 grand so obviously
there's conflict and strife in your
family
so I'm guessing everyone has a big
opinion about this don't they
when did it when did he pass away in
September and what how did he leave it
and life insurance or a beneficiary or
something or what in a 401k a 401k
beneficiary okay yeah all right well you
understand that's taxable when you take
it out right and since it was left to
you you're going to pay the taxes on it
okay and so it's not $12,000 it's all I
know if I stick it into something if
you'd even if you do it's an inherited
IRA is what it turns into
when you roll the forehead that that's
what you can do but even then it's
taxable when you take the money out so
if you take the money out and give it to
them based on 12,500 you will have paid
taxes for them okay so we don't want to
do that for sure that's not right but if
you want to cash it all out and pay your
taxes and after
taxes divvy it up your you can do that
there's nothing wrong with that and I
you know I don't know I mean you've got
to look at your family situation and say
what is the right thing to do here I
guess the main thing that matters is I
guess two things what main thing is what
would your brother want you to do he
should have gone back and changed it it
sounds like because it sounds like he
was back on speaking terms with his kids
and his parents right right and he
didn't do you think he'd want you to
divide it up I think with the tape my
pants are pretty financially stable and
he would take ups with my sister quite a
bit okay so you can just make a decision
say I think this is what he'd want to do
it was all left to me and I don't know
what to do but this is the best I can
come up with I'm gonna give some of the
kids I mean you could do that right but
your sisters gonna be she's gonna be all
twisted anyway isn't she yeah and your
parents don't need the money so there
are they gonna be upset about this no
okay so your sisters upset about
everything anyway all the time so we're
not gonna worry about her cuz you're not
gonna make her happy no matter what all
right yeah okay and if you want to give
some of the kids that's fine but here's
the deal
cash it out and set the taxes and then
after tax give them money not out of
twelve five but more like out of 9 grand
okay you know would you put it in
because they all under 18 oh geez
how old are they - six months and seven
are you not speaking to a two-year-old
he was talking to the kids he wasn't
talking to the time my class oh okay I
thought you said he was estranged from
his kids no not from that
okay why did he not have them as the
beneficiary um I don't know he said that
before they were born and okay what do
you make a year I make 50 okay and my
wife made it's a hundred and four
together if I were in your shoes what I
would do is sit down with a smart Wester
Pro and I would open three accounts and
the kids names as I call custodial
accounts mutual funds and the kids names
and you're the custodian you watch over
the money for the good of these kids on
the behalf of your brother he should
have left this money to his kids not you
and that's what I wouldn't keep any of
it if I were in your shoes these are
little kids they have nothing do I
thought these were grown kids that were
mad at their dad and the way you were
talking about this earlier but this is a
little two-year-old kid they don't know
anything and so yeah I'm gonna roll this
into an inherited IRA and manage it for
them you can let somebody know that it's
it's in your name but you're gonna take
care of it for the kids and if anybody
doesn't like that they can bite your
ankle you know it's yours you can do
with it what you want but I would set it
aside in an inherited IRA let it grow at
some point you could roll it into mutual
funds and the kids name and with
yourself as a custodian but in my mind
if I'm you I'm gonna keep control of
this money and manage it for these kids
and I'm gonna give it all to them at
some point and I'm gonna manage it for
them that's what your brother should
have been doing anyway so good question
thanks for calling in